[Musique]
cela a commencé avec un site Web et
si je faisais le site Web, l'idée était que vous
savez que je veux obtenir ces maîtres
le plus rapidement possible, donc
garanti comme une livraison de 48 heures
vous les enverrait et après quelques
jours
euh, je ne me souviens pas comment j'ai juste pensé que
ce ne serait pas fantastique de les mettre dans des
distributeurs automatiques
pour que les gens puissent simplement aller jusqu'à une
machine de salle choisir le maître qu'ils
veulent et le prendre et cela
les rendrait également facilement accessibles depuis
des centres commerciaux
euh des parcs à thème des zoos partout où quelqu'un
voulait aller
et qu'avez-vous donc,
espérons-le, avec des personnes obligatoires devant
porter des masques, cela donnera beaucoup
plus de confiance aux gens
pour sortir et faire du shopping et
avoir moins peur
du virus et de sa transmission,
donc je pense que jusqu'à
Noël, nous sommes  va continuer à voir une
augmentation de la demande
sur ce but du masquage est de donner aux
gens quelque chose d'autre achetez un noir pour
correspondre à votre tenue
achetez un rose pour correspondre à votre tenue rose
et amener les gens à se sentir à
l'aise de porter un couvre-visage
sans  sortir avoir l'air d'un chirurgien
ou d'un docteur
s'habituer à ça se
familiariser avec
[Musique] [
Musique] [
Musique] étrangère